show me your mattress profile no  jennifer  gab  baby steps  okay there we go all right quite nice  actually  oh my god we're not using your corporate  headshot as your profile photo  jeff what's your first date gonna be  webinar this is exactly why it's fine  okay there's no judgment but  that was a really bad choice  oh okay oh my god are you swiping yes of  course come on it's a numbers game all  right after about 500 swipes you're  gonna get about a third of those as  matches and then that's when the real  filtering happens  oof heterolife is great nikki you're not  helping yes i am come on this is good  what if you made a profile  hear me out  as she-hulk  i thought you hated the name she-hulk i  do but i don't know i can't stop saying  it it's really catchy no if i'm gonna  date it's gonna be as gen  regular old den